yeah you know what welcome to this video
are in no answer you upon a time yeah
that's a new one so maybe we get some
English opening here I went c5 no he
actually transpose to society uh-huh
don't see that too often or this one I
don't know I don't really have a great
line available again sirasa limo it's
not one of my regular opening sent for
black I still think that this is a this
is a well-known line I'm h3 here whoa
oftentimes pushing gvoice plate after c3
so I understand the point
yeah at the end it will look like every
dope ass anyway maybe d phi huh my
knight doesn't really have great squares
but ok it's acceptable the it's such a
closed position you can renew them maybe
you can play d 598 night xe5 de 5d6 for
the pair of bishops it could be
interesting no so here I am do I go be
five I think I do ok
maybe either round two to play the night
on e 3 2 day 5 I was just thinking maybe
I should have played an early age 6
answered a rupee eight but ok then this
cannot be a huge problem yep assure
pitchforks normal ok he can trade them
it's not not terrible too smooth but
Bishop edge for certainly is the more
conventional looking way of playing this
[Music]
9h sci-fi looks technically maybe
technically shaking that takes only
seven tips on you five age 59 is hanging
I would like to trade the dark squared
Bishop same maybe I can still do that
95.5 queen age five I can take d for
twice it could be all right maybe you
just place 93 or something and I can't
eat define default problem ed ZD looking
for the most principled movie is by far
95
I'm fairly happy that the dark squared
Bishop lon so okay that looks it doesn't
look very threatening let's put the
night back in the game and the tech you
form ed c d and e forse hanging ok so
cannot cheat with it I can take with a
knife now I just even pour it's okay I
wonder about 84 if this is something
that could be useful for him I think
I'll go see for in this case gain some
space you know okay suiza taking the c5
pawn Oh
hmm
so a little bit that's a very very
unpleasant ok it couldn't be six I can't
play it looks look somewhat shaky let's
do it maybe it's ok i mean if i go look
the aid next and threatening the bishop
moved to trap the Queen so this is not
all positive FM and move like 93 I will
grab your form just for nothing it could
be ok for me relief maybe I'm
overlooking some technical idea but I
don't see anything at the moment wow
just did not react to this idea at all I
mean now I should have a some some very
substantial discovery next I mean the
Queen has slowed squares and I will move
the bishop in reply so even Bishop g4
comes into consideration but easiest is
to just take age three let's grab it
okay Bishop g4 looks best provoking f3
no it doesn't do that okay so i cannot
go see for what I blunders the Queen
okay but i can double on the deef i'll
wait and see going before in this case
ya mean look at this matter f94 take and
now you force the usual way to do it for
95 let's do it time morning 93 so yeah I
think just the ending is good I don't
know if I can get more but this is very
blending white forfeits on time okay so
it was a pretty strategic game here out
of the Russell emo I'm kind of
questioning if I've is correct but I
don't know h3n was not very much on my
radar think they usually played this
school after which Bishop g4 is play of
course h3 cannot be bad it looks Doctor
completely completely normal okay if I
was a little bit of games because of my
history in the Spanish opening maybe d5
as appreciated rest is really a good
movement I don't really have I don't
have good squares and I was thinking
also about this maybe there is a
technical issue now k not an issue it's
just that white has gotten the bishop
pair but it doesn't do all that much
okay my development is quite good and
93 quickly play be five hmm oh I didn't
see that yeah hmm yeah it's here not on
youtube so here I would have won a pawn
it's not not super clear because Michael
20 nation isn't perfect but stone k h 6
and 9 h 5 yeah the only thing possible
yeah I think to endanger this is Knight
takes I was thinking of that this should
be okay this is kind of this kind of
position but maybe I'm wrong to stand
and say equal okay so at least I wasn't
completely of them aged 3 is a bit bit
bit slow edgy 3 i'm sorry is a bit slow
computer wants to do this but this I
feel awesome should not be terrible for
me maybe a forum it's not exactly a
fantastic way and here i think star
things started to turn around in my
favor a little bit he simply did not
react to update now with the snide edge
form okay bishop h3 immediately also was
on but this is not a bad man you just
bring material for no particular
compensation
here blackest is basically winning and
our incest probably cuz I was better
until 26 yeah that's probably true no I
had some opportunities earlier but
didn't take them ya hear some a4 maybe
you can computer gives equal but I
understand why you think so he could be
better the only question is is my
somewhat exposed queenside can you get
something substantial there I just need
like one or two moves to co-coordinator
am Bishop 657 or so and I'm totally fine
so I don't think there's much but I
understand why he prefers white okay
thanks for watching